breaking years of tradition publisher
Electronic Arts has announced it will
not have a booth on the e3 2016 show
floor this year and it's briefing will
take place Sunday afternoon instead of
later in the week EA is calling this new
event EA play and the press conference
will take place at the nokia theatre
which is right next to the Los Angeles
Convention Center the event is scheduled
for june twelfth at one p.m. pacific
standard time last year bethesda held
its first-ever III briefing on the
sunday evening before e3 so this isn't
the first time a conference hit so early
in the week however with fallout poor's
launched last year it's unlikely the
pyth esta will have a separate
standalone conference of its own this
year though EA won't have its regular
booth in the Los Angeles Convention
Center southall the FIFA and battlefield
publisher will host private meetings a
representative told GameSpot EA has
rented club nokia for june twelfth
through the 14th during which the public
can stop in to try out new games taken
live events and purchase memorabilia
among other things a similar event will
be held at London's the mermaid on jun
12 the good news is that tickets will be
free but you'll need to reserve them
ahead of time due to limited space the
bad news is that hoop gods return has
not yet been confirmed III 2016 will run
from jun 14 to the 16th and you'll be
able to read all about it on gamespot
com
you